e a pessoa quando ela termina o namoro
tudo que era para ela fazer depois que
ela terminou o namoro ela faz o
contrário ela se entufa dentro de casa
em verdade ela escutar uma música legal
a música pracinha bacana não o que que
ela faz ô vagabundo
aí o que é que ela faz se ela tentar
esquecer a pessoa não ela fica entrando
no Whatsapp pô 9:00 da noite e a pessoa
que terminou tiver visualizado o
WhatsApp 3 horas da tarde que é que ela
pensa meu Deus tá [__] desde 3 horas
da tarde até agora meu Deus eu não sei
mas eu vou bater na minha vida
se a pessoa que ela terminou tiver
online naquele momento ela não fica
feliz no mínimo ela tá conversando com
algumas BBB bombado e meu Deus
tu quer que a pessoa que você terminou
tá pensando eu sabia que quando ele
demorava no banheiro não era cagando era
conversando com alguma vagabunda já tá
pegando outra menina ô meu Deus
ninguém tá pegando ninguém